media mob is melting down tonight after
virginia governor glenn younkin and the
state's new leadership they're actually
following through on their campaign
promises like ending you know draconian
mass mandates and standing up to
indoctrination in schools actually
giving parents a say in their kids
education and standing up against
one-size-fits-all medicine with the
failed fake news fraud jimmy acosta fake
news acosta well this is somehow similar
to the former soviet union take a look
in office than less than two weeks and
governor
glenn younkin has already set up an
email tip line for parents to report
teachers for teaching quote divisive
subject you know i seem to remember
glenn younkin campaigning in a fleece
vest in virginia he was running as a
different kind of republican i was told
there was going to be a vest
not a soviet-style police state across
the potomac from washington
there's fake news acosta's soviet-style
police state giving students and parents
freedom whether to mask is actually
jimmy the opposite of a soviet police
state embracing freedom of thought
standing up to left-wing propaganda
indoctrination is literally the opposite
of a soviet police state imagine living
in a far left bubble that you actually
think individual freedom is something
that is evil but of course it didn't
stop there as extreme far left singer
john legend he's now calling on his
followers to flood a new virginia tip
line for parents to blow the whistle on
crt being taught in schools the
leadership in virginia they're standing
strong they're doing what they said they
would do here with reaction the virginia
attorney general jason miaris is back
with us um
i remember a moment in the campaign
against terry terry mcauliffe where
glenn younkin actually said no parents
should have a say in their kids
education and i remember probably the
biggest blunder of the campaign when
terry mcauliffe said they shouldn't have
a say in their kids education
mr attorney general am i right on that
recollection
well you think sean you're exactly right
i mean what the entire campaign a lot of
what it was is saying parents matter and
voters responded to that and i think
what jim acosta said i mean listen my
family fled communist cuba the miara's
family you want to talk about what
soviet style looks like it's the
opposite of freedom i mean my mother has
distinct memories of being forced to
take classes in marxist leninism of
seeing her brother my uncle angel miara
is getting arrested in the middle of the
night by castro's secret police with no
due process no sense of bill of rights
of seeing their family home nationalized
all in the name of fairness and equity
so clearly jim acosta maybe needs to
take some history classes of what
soviet-style communism actually looks
like and that's the opposite what we
have said is parents matter listen if
you're a parent sean and you want to
mask your child for six seven eight
hours a day you absolutely have that
right that's your individual decision
but if you're also a parent with a child
that has asthma or a child who has
glasses that are constantly fogging up
you also have that right and that's what
a pluralistic society looks like
recognize other people are going to come
to different conclusions and by the way
when you reference terry mcauliffe
the code of virginia says parents have a
fundamental right to the upbringing and
well-bringing of their children and the
great irony of all this sean is in
soviet-style communist states like cuba
the state diminishes parents they say
your loyalty is to the state and parents
have less control this is about parental
empowerment this is exactly what you
just said this is what freedom looks
like let's parents make these decisions
not a one size fits all for everybody in
every school and that's exactly what
we're doing and that's what we're
standing with parents against these far
left school boards that are ignoring the
voices of the parents and the governor
made a promise he would end critical
race theory being taught in school now
um maybe i'm old-fashioned
i went to 12 years of catholic schools
and i had a uniform every one of those
years and
um i don't know we pay more per capita
per student than any other country in
the industrialized world to educate our
kids we come in anywhere between 37 and
and 42nd worldwide we're not getting any
bang for our buck maybe being
old-fashioned i would think reading
writing math uh science uh computers uh
maybe that ought to be the first
priority of of educating our kids and
make sure that our standardized testing
goes up and that every kid is proficient
in all of those subjects wouldn't that
be a better plan
a much better plan and listen what
governor younkin and i heard throughout
the campaign talking to virginia parents
is they were concerned nobody we met
said do not teach the dark chapters of
american history don't teach slavery and
don't teach jim crow they said teach all
of all of history and we are indeed that
last best hope on earth it's the same
last bit hope that gave a second chance
to my family and i've said before
america has given more second chances to
more people for more backgrounds more
faiths more races and more creed than
any country in the history of the world
that also is what we should be teaching
our kids that we're that last best hope
on earth there is no other country like
us and if you don't believe me sean go
to your local courthouse and sit in the
back of the room and watch the
naturalization ceremonies the people in
those rooms they understand this is a
unique special place they cherish
freedom that's exactly what we should be
teaching our kids and you're right our
numbers right now with the shutdown of
our schools our math scores our reading
scores it has been
devastating for so many children in
virginia and across this country it's
time we get back our kids back in school
we let parents decide what's happening
with the mass teach them the basic as
governor younkin loves to say we want to
teach them what to think not how to
think that's what we're talking about in
virginia and we're ready to get started
explain the tip line really quickly
if parents have a problem in their
school system
who will go through that tip line and
and look into matters that might be
serious
listen all this is saying is parents
have a right if they find out there's
something that's really concerning them
and we're seeing school board after
school board and loudon and all over
that candidly are just ignoring parents
voices they're not allowing them to
speak in some cases parents are getting
arrested we're saying listen we believe
in accountability and transparency in
government that's all we believe in and
the idea is allowing parents to have a
voice one more voice where they can
actually express their concerns and so
that would obviously go to the younkin
administration but the whole idea of
this is parental empowerment and if
school boards are ignoring their parents
we're going to try to give them as many
avenues whatsoever and this is no
different than when school boards accept
email solicitation of what's going on
from the general public we're just
saying listen we just want to know
what's going on give us the information
if you're concerned hey just let us know
this is about parental involvement and
parental empowerment and that's our goal
here all right we appreciate mr attorney
general you've been back with us when we
come back proof the left is more
concerned with ukraine's border than our
own plus exclusive reporting from sarah
carter and julio rosas exposing the
biden administration what they really
think about the crisis on our southern
border we've got an update you won't get
anywhere else